there are tons of production companies
that have reached out and networks that
want to do a show we're going to touch
on where we're at today mom and dad
being gone how we're coping with it the
Chrisley family is planning a TV
comeback because what we have to do what
we gotta work right we have a fan base
now we want to make them proud Savannah
Chrisley opens up on her unlocked
podcast getting candid about her
family's new reality with parents Todd
and Julie serving their combined 19-year
prison sentence obviously the past few
months have been difficult but we're
getting there what we will not do is we
will not break
while Savannah's Mom and Dad plead their
innocence from behind bars she's
plotting another behind-the-scenes look
at their family life there are tons of
production companies that have reached
out and networks that
want to do a show we'll show we'll say
well look at these uh bounce back
Chrisleys bounce back Chrisleys on the
latest pod Savannah's joined by
matriarch Nanny Faye Todd's Mom
Savannah's Grandma so I gotta guess
where we need to turn because she won't
tell me Nanny phase a fan favorite and
over on Instagram she and Savannah's
younger brother Chase reminded fans why
and what just happened Annie what made a
mistake
it's real hard but you know what just
have faith and believe and know that
tomorrow is a new day we don't know
what's going to happen look any family
who faces a loved one going to prison
it's a very difficult challenge but
they're strong they're faithful and I
think they'll continue in that way
forward but in the wake of Todd and
Julie's imprisonment following their
convictions for bank fraud and a tax
evasion charges they deny
fans shouldn't expect the happy-go-lucky
Vibes of Chrisley Knows Best on any
future shows I feel like a new show is
going to be
reality we're going to touch on where
we're at today mom and dad being gone
how we're coping with it I'm not gonna
lie a new show it'll break your heart
I've never seen two people my parents be
so steadfast in their faith in the end
the truth will prevail may get harder
before it gets easier but we have faith
Savannah's dream of bringing a more
serious series to life comes after Todd
and Julie teased a new project before
surrendering to prison the documentary
that's being that we're working on right
now is going to be very telling and we
hope that our fans will Embrace that
what do you know about this documentary
and the message that the Chrisley family
wants to now show the world I don't have
any details about the documentary uh I
can just tell you there is there is a
story there about what they've been
through the past year or two that hasn't
been told and we're going to let the
world see that we're really who we were
we love each other we're going to walk
this walk and talk this towel no further
details on the show for now but we do
know they're workshopping titles
bounce back Christmas no yeah Nanny's
Knows Best
[Music]